[Music]
you could see it from space
shown in red china's air pollution
cleared up dramatically during the great
lockdown
less traffic and closed factories saw
thick smog give way to blue skies
air travel is responsible for seven
percent of greenhouse gases
long-haul flights were down 90 percent
could the lockdown be a road map to a
greener future
we've seen with the drastic measures
that china has taken with regard to
corona that emissions have gone down
seriously so people
are working from home manufacturing is
slowed down
so these are the kinds of drastic
measures that we will have to take for
climate change
no one wants a second lockdown but we've
caught a glimpse of a less polluting
world
the challenge is aiming for that while
avoiding the damage to our livelihoods
and the economy
the blue economy is thriving thanks to
the global quarantine
a disruption to industrial fishing has
seen some fish stocks
explode that's brought back these guys
to places like portugal
but are they here to stay when
everything returns to normal the fish
could run out again
we'll bring you that report in a moment
first german chancellor angela mekkel
says the world's not doing enough to
combat climate change
she's pledged to accelerate efforts
felix croissier is from the mcat oil
research institute on global commons and
climate change
felix how do you balance the planet's
needs and
ours does it mean changing our
consumption habits
it may mean that we have learned now
from the covert 19 crisis that actually
working from home or flying less
meaning like having holidays at home can
be equally nice
so there are options and we learned that
this is not possible
to do so but obviously what we cannot do
that we have like a constant lockdown we
force and such
options instead we need like a
structural change the supportable policy
instruments
and enable us to have this low calm
lifestyles
without structural change we are not
going there and at a political level
europe's largest greenhouse gas emitter
is germany and germany would have missed
its 2020 climate targets hadn't it been
for the pandemic it slashed emissions
basically for us
angela merkel wants a carbon pricing
mechanism for the eu's industry and
transport sectors is
is that an answer in your opinion
yes definitely like economists
consistently say that carbon pricing is
one of the best options in place
um and like if you have uh economic
right account price of more than 50
euros a time that's a huge step forward
so we can when we applaud uh chancellor
merkel to look over that
but of course we need also supplementary
policies for example
if you want to be carbon neutral in 2050
it means that phasing out of combustion
engines quite quickly
and unique support for the german car
industry and also the jobs of course to
master
adjust transition well that's the
biggest concern i guess is jobs because
if you start getting industry or all
these companies
trying to foot the bill i'm sure they're
going to say well
we're going to have to lay off staff
no no definitely drops a big issue but
the good news is that
new industries collect renewables shared
mobility
they also offer new job opportunities
digitization also high quality jobs
so it's really about like getting into
these new jobs and not
despairing about the old jobs also on a
personal level i i can't believe the
amount of
discarded masks i've seen on streets
people
just don't seem to get it i mean it's
hard enough to get them to wear a mask
in the first place but they can't even
throw it into a bin afterwards
how do you get the health of our planet
through to people
i i'm more optimistic i think we have
all learned a lesson here that's we need
to act together
to combat the pandemic and actually we
didn't do so back in here
honor us have to respect the
masks and etcetera to us to stop or to
reduce the infection rate
and this kind of hold a collective
action exactly is also needed to
save planetary health and we have seen
that this can actually be effective so
i'm more optimistic here
because i mean you you do see that
people are very
worried very scared about their health
all of a sudden
um and and it's a disconnect almost
because
the health of our planet i mean a
healthy planet would
mean a lot healthier lifestyles for us
definitely that's the interesting thing
like eating
less meat or moving more with bicycles
also
is healthier for us and healthy for the
planet and i think
you have to get our mindset into that
but of course we need support like
without
safe bicycle lanes without like
affordable vegetable foods everywhere
this and this won't be easy
yeah it's obviously a two street felix
koitis
from the mercator research institute on
global commons and climate change
thanks very much for being on the show
today thank you
well on the state of our oceans the last
time a global crisis hit the fishing
industry
was the second world war the closure of
the north sea allowed
cod and haddock to thrive there were big
catches throughout
the 1950s something similar
is happening in portugal
for the people of lisbon this is nothing
short of a small miracle
dolphins have returned to the river
targash estuary
as a biologist inish clara often went
dolphin watching in the azores
today she works as a sailing instructor
but because of the pandemic
finding work is tough especially because
there are no
tourists
but enosh and her boss say this is a
silver lining
this year there are more sardines and
mackerel in the ocean
that's what the dolphins like feeding on
specifically they're a massive 50 kilo
stone bass as well
huge sea bass and we've never seen this
many sardines
they say the water quality of river
targash has improved a lot due to the
lockdown
that and the decline in industrial
fishing has encouraged the dolphins to
return
and the fact that no noisy cruise ships
are harboring in the portuguese capital
helps too
as dolphins are very sensitive to noise
[Music]
large ships are very invasive dolphins
are disturbed by them
and avoid swimming up the river mount
invasives
and imagine the huge vessels are not
docking here right now
due to the pandemic the authorities in
lisbon are using this time to make the
city more environmentally friendly
they've pledged that by 2022 docked
cruise ships must stop their motors to
reduce emissions
eventually every cruise ship docked in
lisbon will have to be connected to the
electricity grid
to reduce sulfur oxide emissions and cut
pollution
in the city
enish hopes that the expected
improvement in water quality and decline
in noise pollution will keep the fish
and the dolphins near the beach
that way lisbon could live up to its
nickname of europe's green capital
long after the pandemic is over
and what better time to ask if the
global battle against the coronavirus
is actually working let's take a little
look at the most
up-to-date data that's come through from
over 200 countries and territories
new cases have doubled in 29 countries
and increased in 70 countries in all
new case numbers stayed at the same
level in 10 nations
73 countries have seen new positive
cases for covert 19 go down
newly reported case numbers halved in 16
countries
and 11 have reported no new cases for
four weeks in a row
here's the bar graph stacked up against
the statistics of the last weeks
remember the battle is one when that
entire chart is blue
there's a long way to go
and now that part of the show when derek
williams takes over the helm
our science correspondent has been
looking into your questions on the
coronavirus
what's dangerous is the pneumonia why
not find a cure
or treatment for the pneumonia instead
of the virus
pneumonia is a blanket term that's
generally defined
as a more or less serious inflammation
of tissue in in your air passages and or
your lungs
it can be caused by a number of
different pathogens both both viral
and bacterial the pneumonia that covert
19 can cause
is generally initiated by the virus and
can't be treated for example uh with
antibiotics
which only kill bacteria um when they're
infected with saurus cove too
the cells in the small sacks in your
lungs where gas exchange occurs what are
called
um the alveoli begin to die
and clog the lungs up and and that can
eventually lead to what's called
acute respiratory distress syndrome
as the pneumonia progresses the
situation can be exacerbated
by the immune system causing massive
inflammation
which is which is supposed to help get
the infection under control but which
can actually make things worse so so
treating
or curing coronavirus pneumonia means
either addressing the problem at its
root which is
the sars co2 infection itself or somehow
toning down the body's immune response
to it when it goes
over the top